justamente algunos analistas y los
opositores a Dina boluarte están
criticando a la mandataria peruana por
hacer estos cambios en medio de la
extradición de Alejandro Toledo están
señalando que la mandataria peruana está
Aprovechando que todo el país está
centrado en Toledo para hacer los
cambios en lo que es el Ministerio de
Educación el Ministerio de trabajo el
Ministerio de Justicia y el Ministerio
de comercio donde los jefes de estas
carteras ministeriales están siendo
cuestionados por diversas acciones que
han realizado Tina boluarte se encuentra
afrontando en estos momentos el punto
más alto de impupolaridad con un 77% el
margen más largo de desaprobación en lo
que ha ocurrido desde que asumió el
poder de este país el Palacio de
Gobierno ha programado que en unos
minutos va a estar juramentando los
nuevos integrantes
del gabinete de Dina boluarte hay mucha
expectativa en Perú tanto de lo que
sucede con respecto al traslado de
Alejandro Toledo a la prisión de
barbadío como los cambios y probables
anuncios que haga la presidenta de ir a
boluarte o el Primer Ministro de este
país Alberto tarola les estaremos
llevando información más adelante en
Francia 24